the fact that we get to share in this
rather unparalleled experience for us
both right now is just it's it's still
something we're having trouble digesting
you know it's everything I know that it
most likely won't ever get this good
again in that way because I mean it was
just one of those things where she's the
greatest collaborator I've ever had in
my career John Krasinski and Emily Blunt
reflecting on their experience making a
mega-hit a quiet place we made this
together we loved working together we
want to work together again and the fact
that people love it
you know it's just been huge to have it
be your wife and to have your wife be by
your side through something like this
and not just experience it alone and
have to go back home and tell somebody
about it you know to actually get to
experience the most thrilling moment in
your career such a huge shift in your
life together is amazing presents key
[Applause]
the couple was honored at the SCAD
Savannah
Film Festival for their work on the
movie I mean I don't think we ever
imagined that the film would receive
this sort of stratospheric reaction that
it did I mean it's a small movie it
wasn't made for very much and Jonah is
wanting to make an art movie about the
metaphor of parenthood and yet it just
took people by surprise and it just the
word spread like quick-firing before we
knew it the movie was just this huge hit
so no it was not expected yeah and soon
it's hopefully back to work on the quiet
place sequel i I do I mean I'm gonna let
John speak to the sequel I did because
it's all sort of just slowly per me like
permeating right now you know I'm
writing it right now that's all I am I'm
just I'm right there I'm sort of just
thinking about it it's one of those
things where I actually didn't know that
I would want to be a part of it at all
the sequel because we loved the first
one we thought it was sort of a one-off
type of deal but you realize that it's
not a character or a group of people
it's a world that you get to explore and
explore different perspectives and
different avenues of who's in this world
and who else is out there
[Music]
[Applause]